Der berühmte Stern, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, von Van Gogh, der Abendmeldung, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, herzlich willkommen auch von mir. Mein Name ist Fortuny Will, mir gegenüber sitzt natürlich wie immer der gute alter Stefan Rodolfo Stitzer. Hallo. Hallo. Tolles Intro, sehr schönes Intro von Phil, vielen Dank, der sich nochmal den Van Gogh Sternenhimmel angenommen hat und ihn nochmal weiter vertont hat. Und so klingt er eigentlich. So klingt er eigentlich, das heißt, wir haben jetzt ein Bild zu einem Ton gemacht, der Ton wird wiederum weiterverarbeitet und aus dem werden wir wieder ein Bild machen. Jetzt müssen wir es eigentlich umkehren, jetzt müssen wir aus Ton ein Bild machen, das wird dann wieder weiter gemalt von Menschen, von Künstlern und das wird wieder zu einem Ton und dann kommt alles zusammen. Bis es sich irgendwann so verwässert und einfach langweilig nur noch ein schwarz-weiß Strichmännchen ist. Ja, letzten Endes ist es ja ein Film. Wir nehmen dann alle Bilder nebeneinander, frame, letztendlich ist es ein langweiliger Film. Letztendlich ist es ein sehr experimenteller, sehr langweiliger, extrem kurzer Film. Ja. Weil selbst wenn du alle Frames nebeneinander packst, hast du am Ende noch eineinhalb Sekunden. Was ist der langweiligste Film, den du niemals gesehen hast? Boah, das ist schon einfach nur langweilig, wo du sagst, warum gucke ich das jetzt? Das ist glaube ich schwierig, weil man sich gar nicht so unbedingt daran erinnert. Also es ist halt die Frage, was ist der Unterschied zwischen langweilig und schlecht? Also das ist dann oft so, wenn man einfach nicht gepackt wird, sowas wie Justice League oder so, fand ich grauenvoll, der war so lang und so viel Zeug, wie ich nicht verstanden habe. Ich habe neulich einen Film geguckt, wo ich vergessen hatte, den ich schon mal gesehen hatte, weil er so vergesslich war. Ich habe jetzt gerade wieder vergessen, was für ein Film war. Das war erst am Wochenende. Vielleicht komme ich gleich drauf. Ich habe ihn schon wieder vergessen. Ja, vor allem das Gefährliche ist, du kannst Leute nicht vor dem Film warnen. Der ist jetzt in der Welt und Leute werden ihn anschauen. Ich glaube, niemand erinnert sich an diesen Film. Nee, und niemand sagt, Alter, schau den Film nicht an. Aber alle haben diese Ahnung im Kopf, dass sie einen Film gesehen haben, der langweilig war. Ja. Wenn ihr auch nicht wisst, was ihr am Wochenende gemacht habt, so am Samstagabend, so zwischen neun und zwölf, habt ihr vielleicht auch den Film geguckt? So, Stefan, guck mal, hier ist ein neuer Film rausgekommen, The Long Field. Soll ich mir den anschauen? Ja. Okay. Du konntest mich jetzt nicht warnen, dass der Film langweilig ist, weil du dich nicht daran erinnert hast. Ja, okay, guck ich mit. Und beim Film geht einem so auf, oh, fuck der. Ach ja, aber genau so war's. Ich erinnere mich nur so schemenhaft an Dinge. War das nicht ... Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war. Es war, ich glaub, so was Mythologie-artiges ... Ä, God, War of Titans oder God of Titans, sowas in der Richtung. War of the Ancients? War of the Titans? War of the Titans? Ja, sowas in der Richtung. Titans waring around. Irgendwann muss eine internationale Krisenkonferenz gestartet werden. Es gibt da diesen Film, der theorisiert unsere Kinos und Heimkinos, aber wir wissen nicht, welcher es ist. Die Weltwirtschaft stockt. Warum? Wir haben die Vermutung.
Ideen, also erste Ideen. Kamerun wegen Inline Skates. Gut, schreiben wir auf den Zettel.
Wer hat noch Ideen, warum stockt die Weltwirtschaft? Belgien.
Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, ich bin von der FBI, von dem Federal Bureau, dem Büro, streng genommen, dem FBI. Okay. Wir haben herausgefunden, warum die Weltwirtschaft stockt. Es gibt angeblich im Jahre 2006 diesen Film, der in die Kinos gekommen ist, an den ich aber nie mehr erinnern kann. Ich bin Filmkonnoisseur, ich kann mich an alle Filme erinnern, die 2006 rausgekommen sind. Haben Sie schon bei den Filmen War of the Titans, The Titans Are Coming gehört? Nee. Was sagt man, War of the ... War of the World? Richtig, 2006 kam War of the Titans, The Titans Are Running Around and Warring Around in die Kinos. Niemand erinnert sich an diesen Film. Der Film wird immer wieder geguckt. Hat irgendjemand hier im Raum den Film gesehen? Okay, hier ist er. Kann sich irgendjemand an den Film erinnern? Können Sie mir kurz das Hade-Me-Kabel geben? Ja, sorry. Wir haben leider nur die kurzen. Entschuldigung, das ist hier neben der Schweiz. Schweiz, können Sie kurz? Und der Beamer, können Sie den kurz anmachen? Können wir die Fenster irgendwie verdunkeln? Ist auch nicht so, ich will nur kurz den Film, hat jemand Flaggen dabei? Nein, das ist nicht so schlimm, ich will nur den Film kurz anmachen. Alles da, okay. Können wir Popcorn machen, wollen wir Popcorn machen? Ja, aber ganz kurz erstmal den Film anmachen. Okay, salziges, ihr esst alle Süsses, oder? Ja, wenn jetzt alle Süss essen, dann würde ich kein salziges nehmen. Aber wenn jetzt einer auch salzig... Naja, USA will salzig, oder? Wer will noch salzig? Botswana wirklich? Ihr auch salzig?
Hätte ich nicht gedacht. Ihr auch salzig.
Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht. Ich würde was mit dem Film anmachen.
Moment, dann haben wir drei. Belgien, Botswana, USA.
Belgien? Belgien ist nur Hauptpopcorn, hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Aber ...
Okay, dann warte, ich gehe kurz in die Küche.
Schnitt, drei Stunden später.
So, ich will jetzt den Film anmachen.
Gut. Play-Taste. Toll! Ohne Scheiss, ich mach kurz auf Stopp.
Was eine coole Musik.
Toll, oder?
Super.
Jerry Goldsmith hat es übrigens gemacht.
Ja.
Ja, Jerry Goldsmith fuhr für Universal.
Aber die neue Version ist, glaube ich, nicht mehr von ihm.
Wurde ein bisschen unkompliziert.
Ich mach wieder auf Play.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie diesen Film schon mal gesehen?
Nein.
Warten Sie kurz ab. Werden Sie sich langsam an den Film erinnern. Psst. Jetzt? Psst. Macht es Klick oder? Sie haben all diesen Film schon mal gesehen. Das ist der Grund. Nicht Botswana. Nee, das ist... Ja, irgendwie sowas. Aber war das nicht so mit Troja oder Alexander oder so? Ich spiele kurz vor. Ich spiele kurz vor. Hier. Und? Wie kann jemand nichts süssiges, süsses Popcorn mögen, oder? Sorry, Belgien. Belgien, greift mal rein. Ernsthaft. das ist doch nicht euer scheiß Ernst. Warum sprechen Sie Belgien konstant auf Deutsch an? Kann doch nicht besser sein als das. Greif mal rein. Greif rein, wirklich. Nimm eine. Nimm eine Hand. Warum sind wir noch mal hier? Weil die Wirtschaft stockt. Ja, aber warum stockt sie? Ja, das ist die Frage. Wir haben, ich gucke kurz auf den Zettel, wir haben eine Idee von Kamerun Rollerblades. Sonst hatten wir keine Idee. Kamerun sagt Rollerblades. Nein, der Zettel ist leer, wir haben gerade angefangen, dann sind sie reingestürmt. Mit dem Popcorn, dann kam ich an mit dem Popcorn, ne? Ja, und dann haben sie irgendwas von irgendeinem Film erzählt, aber... Film? Nee, nee. Sie haben gesagt Popcorn und dann... Ja, und dann... Und die Welt wurde weiter geplagt von diesem langweiligen Film. Das ist unser Film. Das ist wiederum unser Film. Perspectives? Perspectives. Finding Pandori? Das ist unser Film. Das ist unser Film und der ist auch so langweilig, dass es zum gleichen Problem führt, was thematisiert wird. Apropos Finding Pandora, wir haben letzte Woche ja ausgerufen zu einem Crossover Limerick. Also wir haben gesagt, wir haben Pandora nochmal neu belebt und unglaublich beliebt ist Pandora. Pandora ist unglaublich beliebt und es kam ganz viel... Der Film Pandora. Nee, die Welt Pandora. Die Leute lieben Avatar. Die Leute lieben Avatar und alle freuen sich auf Avatar 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 und 7 und können es kaum erwarten und müssen sich ihre Zeit quasi totschlagen mit Limericks, die Welten kreuzen. Da kam zum Beispiel ein fantastisches Limerick. Achtung! Einst fand ein Navi auf Pandora ein Schiff, das da noch nicht zuvor war.
Es ist die Titanic 2. Sie reist in Avatar 3 samt Eisberg durchs All nach Pandora. Okay, finde ich gut. Toll, von Tim, vielen Dank für die ... Und das war immer mit kurz. Ja, das war kurz. Es wird ab jetzt jede Woche die kürzeste Crossover-Story vorgelegt. Es wird ein Limerick, ein kurzer Limerick verlesen. Ja, also vielen Dank an Tim für diesen fantastischen Limerick. Finde ich sehr gut. Kann das mal jemand meiner Hausaufgabe an euch, aber so eine Zusatzaufgabe, wenn es sich ergibt, wenn ihr in der Kirche seid und ihr werdet ausgewählt für Fürbitten, dann lest das vor. Lest das vor. Oder wandelt diesen Limerick in eine Farbe um. Das wäre auch noch meine, also das ist die C-Aufgabe, in eine Farbe oder in einen Ton. Das fände ich auch noch wichtig. Aber ansonsten vielen Dank für den Limerick. Aber du hast schon recht, Antike ist immer schwierig irgendwie. Es gibt viele Filme aus der Antike, die nicht so ganz ... Es ist einfach ... Warum ist Antike nicht so cool wie Mittelalter? Hercules habe ich aber auch geschaut neulich mal wieder. Die Disney-Serie. Den Disney-Film. Den Disney-Film? Den Disney-Film Hercules habe ich aus den nostalgischen Gefühlen heraus geschaut. Und Wahnsinn, das ist ja ein Musical. Wie cool ist das denn? Da wurde die ganze Zeit gesungen, getanzt. Und ich war so unterhalten von Herkules, Herkules auch unterschätzt, man hat Herkules nicht auf dem Zettel. Wenn du die besten Disney-Filme und die besten Disney-Songs im Kopf abrufst, Herkules ist nicht oft dabei. Deswegen, das können wir mal machen, die besten Disney-Songs, und ehrlich gesagt ist Herkules ziemlich oben mit dabei. Tolle Lieder. Gerade am Anfang auch, The Gospel Truth, wo die Musen von Herkules erzählen und von den Titanen und Zeus, ganz tolle Musik. Dann, wenn der kleine Satyr dem Herkules alles beibringt, sich aber erst sträubt, dieses typische Denial, erstmal nicht Call to Adventure annehmen, okay, alles klar, nee, kein Bock. So, das alles in den Song verpackt. Das macht spannend. Dann guckt man es sich auch gerne an. Man kennt es ja aus jedem Film, nee, erst mal nicht durch die Pforte schreiten, okay, jetzt doch, hat sich was Gleiches verändert, jetzt bin ich doch bereit. Das in dem Song. Disney hat es in den Song gepackt. Hercules ist toll. Also, klare Schauempfehlung von Stefan Tietze, Hercules, oder wie Leute sagen, die zeigen wollen, dass sie sich mit Kultur auskennen, Herakles. Oh Gott, die langweiligere Version, die Herakles sagen, uh, ich kenne mich aus, ich kenne Geschichte nicht nur durch Filme, sondern auch durch ein Buch. Frage, es ist die Schnittmenge groß zwischen Leuten, die Herakles sagen und Jesu. Ja, das stimmt. Oder? Ja, das ist mal so eine Besteinigung. Leute, die Herakles sagen, Mose und Jesu, die immer so die akademische Variante von allem sagen. Stimmt, Janja. Jesu Christi. Jesu Christi. Mein Gott, Jesus, halt den Mose. Jesus, halt die Fresse. Ja, das ist eine gute Empfehlung. Und dann, weil ich selber meine Ranglässe machen sollte mit den besten Disney-Songs, bin ich wieder auf Tarzan gestossen. Ja. Und Tarzan hat, will ich durch Phil Collins natürlich mit den besten Soundtracks eines Disney-Songs. Spielen Hercules, Aladdin und Mulan eigentlich zur gleichen Zeit an verschiedenen Orten? Du sagst nein, weil Herkules auf Mythologie basiert. Es gibt Porno-Crossovers im Internet, die das jetzt behaupten würden. Weil wir haben ja letzte Woche geredet über Endgame und alles und was kann noch kommen, was hat das Kino überhaupt noch zu bieten oder ist es eine tote Kunstform? Wie wäre es mit Disney-Crossovers? Ja, das war unsere Diskussion. Das war unsere zehnstündige Podiumdiskussion. Aladdin meets Mulan. Ja, ein bisschen boring, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, stimmt schon. Zwei Hauptfiguren ist auch ein bisschen lame. Mulan, auch einen guten Song. Diesen Song, wo sie kämpft. Auch vergessen. Mein Gehirn ist ein Sieb mittlerweile, wirklich. Ja. Aber so ein so grobes Sieb, dass alles durchfällt. Aber was hast du für einen Zeitraum? Also wie viel Zeit hast du, bevor du das Niederschreiben musst? Ehrlich gesagt, auch diese ganze Schachnummer jetzt lässt mich glauben, weil ich kann mir auch sehr gut kurzzeitig Dinge merken. Ich vergesse sie aber danach super schnell wieder. Und dieses ganze Ich kann mich gut in in eine Sache reinfuchsen, kurzzeitig, hat mich zum Nachdenken gebracht.
Ich habe vergessen, was das Ergebnis war.
Nein, aber ich bin zum Ergebnis gekommen, dass ich ein sehr gutes Kurzzeitgedächtnis habe.
Ich kann sehr gut wie ein Schwamm Dinge aufsaugen, kurzzeitig, kann dann sehr schnell lernen und habe dann eine schnelle Auffassungsgabe in dem Moment. Aber das ist null nachhaltig, auch damals, dass ich Japanisch gelernt habe. Ich habe ja hier eine Folge fließend Japanisch gesprochen. Das stimmt, ja, die war wild, die Folge. Und viel mit Gestik auch gearbeitet. Viel mit Gestik und Spanisch. Und da dachte ich dann auch so, krass, ich kann schon schnell eine Sprache lernen.
Jetzt mittlerweile ist nichts mehr über.
Also vielleicht, deswegen ist mein Gehirn vielleicht einfach so komisch verzahnt, dass ich halt nur kurzfristig Dinge kann.
Oder ist es mittlerweile so ein Gesellschaftsding und es liegt auch so ein bisschen an, keine Ahnung, Nine-Gag, Infinite-Feeds, dass wir so sind.
Was meinst du mit dieser Schachsache, du gerade erwähnt hast?
Ich habe was erwähnt? Schach? Schach, ja, ja.
Du warst doch bei diesem Schachturnier, ich habe es gar nicht angeguckt.
Bist du da weit gekommen, oder?
Ach so, ja, also, nee, ich wollte es auch gar nicht erwähnen, das war nur ein Beispiel.
Ach so, wenn du gerade Schach gesagt hast, deswegen dachte ich, du bist, weil du da ganz deutlich auf dich gedeutet hast. Nee, weil ich habe Zugzwang gewonnen. Ach, cool. Ich habe das Schach-Tonier der Rocket Beans. Cool, kommen wir zu unserer nächsten Rubrik. Gewonnen, wo viele Leute mitgemacht haben. Und ja, das war wahnsinnig cool. Also es hat wirklich wahnsinnig viel Spaß gemacht. Ja. Und. Nee, und es war auch so gar nicht so klar, also ... Ja, ich hab mal ... Weil es war schon ziemlich eine Herausforderung, und dann ... Ja, konnte ich das Final dann ganz, ganz knapp noch für mich entscheiden, und es war wirklich super aufregend und wahnsinnig glücklich am Ende, und ja, also ich bin schon stolz. Okay, gut. Ich will mich auch noch mal bedanken dafür, dass du mich auch immer unterstützt hast. Ja. Ja, du hast mich ja, oh, sollen wir das sagen, dass du mich während der Sendung angerufen hast und gesagt hast. Äh, was? Ne, Quatsch. Wie darf nochmal der, der, der, der, der Hut gehen, der mit der Kerbe oben drin, wie darf der nochmal gehen? Wie hieß der nochmal? mal? Die Rakete. Was macht die Rakete noch mal? The Walker, the Walker. Und das Pferd? Nein, aber es war ein cooles Spiel. Du hast Reift besiegt, unglaublich. Und deine erste Teilnahme ist ins Finale geschafft, ungeschlagen. Du hast im gesamten Turnier kein einziges Brett verloren. Deswegen, herzlich willkommen, es war cool anzuschauen. Irakler hat auch nie ein Brett verloren. Es deswegen, herzlichen Glückwunsch war cool anzuschauen.
Miraclex hat auch nie ein Brett verloren.
Es waren auch weirde Spiele.
Ich kenne mich mit Schach nicht aus, ich konnte
nur an den Gesichtsausdrücken der Kommentatoren ablesen,
dass da wilde Dinge passieren auf dem Brett.
An den herausploppenden Augen
konnte man erkennen, dass da nicht alles so
gerade läuft. Was ich aber
schade finde ein bisschen, und ich hoffe, dass sich das
natürlich auch durchsetzen wird für Zugzwang, so heißt es Schachturnier Staffel sechs und sieben, dass ihr euch auch gegenüber sitzt in dem Raum. Weil klar, dieses Online-Ding und so, das ist natürlich auch schon cool und dass auch jeder seine Gedanken aussprechen kann, ist auch manchmal cool, da kann man dann immer so reinfahren. Aber das Potential, auch alle Figuren mit so einer ungeschickten Bewegung vom Bett zu fegen. Vor allem dann auch wirklich lange nachdenken und dann den König nehmen und auf die Seite legen. Allein dafür würde ich in den Schachklub gehen, nur um das in Zug vier einfach zu machen, weil es so cool ist, so dieses, ich bin so schlau, dass ich sehe, das ist jetzt schon vorbei. Ich komme nicht auf deinen Teilnahme im nächsten Turnier. Ich wollte jetzt im Schachverein beitreten, Anmeldestopp beim Kamener Schachverein, weil ich meiner Heimat natürlich treu, ist gerade Anmeldestopp. Bist du sonst in irgendwelchen Vereinen? Kein Verein. Du hast nie wirklich Vereinsleben. Doch, viel Vereinsleben. Es fing an, beim Kamener SC Fußball. Dann war ich im Pfadfinderverein, bei den Wölflingen, Stamm Graalsritter in Kamm. Wölflinge, Stamm Graalsritter. Bei den Wölflingen, entweder bei den Pfadfindern, im Stamm Graalsritter, Bund Weltenbummler in Kamm. Wow. Da war ich... Eine Menge Abzeichen, vier Hüte auf, drei Schärfen. Natürlich, fünf Hüte, achtatten, neunzig Abzeichen, die Weste war voll. Ja, man wusste nicht genau, also man hat so ein Gefühl von Patriotismus gespürt, man wusste nicht, für was, weil die Zugehörigkeit war sehr weit gestreut. Du hattest so viele Farben auf der Brust, du wusstest nicht, ist das überhaupt in Europa? Ich wusste nicht, für wenig bin. Keine Ahnung. Naja, da war ich lange, dann beim VfL kam Tennis, war ich lange, habe ich lange gespielt, Tennis gespielt, wobei ich war, habe bei ein Paarverein, doch, doch, doch. Krass, aber seitdem jetzt nicht mehr. Jetzt kommst du wieder zurück in Schach. Jetzt bin ich wieder, jetzt wollte ich in Schachverein treten, aber, ja, ein Bildes Stopp. Warst du mal in einem Fanclub? Ne. Das ist auch so ein Konzept, das, glaube ich, für alle folgenden Generationen ein Mysterium sein wird. Das ist vielleicht so etwas wie eine Gilde oder eine Loge. Wenn jemand erzählt, so im Mittelalter, ja, da gab es ja verschiedene Handwerkergilden und man nickt das so ab und denkt sich, ja, ja, aber man kann nicht nach Hause. Wie komme ich aus diesem Gespräch raus? Man denkt nur so, fährt der Bus um 14 oder 24? Und man ist raus. Genauso, wenn wir unseren Kindern erzählen, ich war damals in einem Simpsons-Fanclub. Du warst in einem Simpsons-Fanclub? Dann wird das weggenickt. Ja, Moment, nee, das wird jetzt nicht an Achter gelegt. Du warst in einem Simpsons-Fanclub? Nee, ich persönlich war auch nicht in einem Fanclub. Fanklub habe ich noch nie verstanden. Ich finde es fantastisch, weil es ist ein Verein, der eigentlich, glaube ich, nur so Selbstzweck ist, weil du bist in einem Verein, ohne da etwas tun zu müssen. Du gehst, du frönst nur einer Sache, die du eh schon immer ausgeübt hast. Du bist Fan von Borussia Dortmund, dann trittst du einem Fanclub bei, du hast den ganzen Vereinsspaß, die soziale Interaktionen,
wahrscheinlich einfach so auch wöchentliche Rituale,
man trifft sich irgendwie in Stammkneipen oder sowas.
Und?
Und du guckst gemeinsam etwas, was du eh schon immer gut fandest.
Und vielleicht einer der berühmtesten Fanclubs der Welt,
denn alle Fans von der Herr der Ringe
haben vielleicht mal die Extended Edition angeschaut,
die Extended Edition der Herr der Ringe-Filme, die nicht nur unglaublich lang ist, sondern auch extrem lange Abspände hat.
Also teilweise die längsten Abspände der Welt, 40, 50 Minuten lang kommen da Namen.
50 Minuten Abspände?
Unfassbar lang.
Und Howard Shaw so, und da soll ich komplett drüber Musik schreiben oder was?
Ja, klar, natürlich.
Das sind 50 Minuten schwarz Bildschirm mit weissen Armen.
Und dann kommen da nämlich die Namen von sämtlichen Mitgliedern des Fanclubs. Und Howard Shaw versinkt nur im Stuhl, wenn er dieses Dokument erhält. Und es sind einfach hunderte und aber hunderte von Namen von dem Herr der Ringe Fanclub. Aber da denkt man sich, wäre ich doch nur in einem coolen Fanclub, damit ich im fucking Abspann vom Herr der Ringe Extended Edition Film bin.
Nein, da bin ich anders. Da bin ich anders gestrickt.
Du bist doch der Abspannsammler. Du, ich wogelst jedes Mal auf, du zwingst immer die Leute sitzen zu bleiben, bis dein Name erscheint und dann deutest du immer drauf, der kommt ja schon im Vorspann. Hahaha.
Hahaha.
Ähm, nee.
Ich will doch nicht, wenn ich im Abstand von Herrn der Ringe bin, dann will ich auch was
geleistet haben.
Dann will ich nicht nur Herrn der Ringe gut finden. Warum stehen die überhaupt da drin? Stehen die als Förderer da drin? Haben die Geld gegeben? Nein. Die stehen drin, weil sie es gut finden? Ja, wenn sie es gut finden. Oder die haben vielleicht irgendwas gemacht, die haben vielleicht irgendwie da Bilder gemalt. Wer war denn vor dem Film auch Herr der Ringe-Fan? Ich weiß es doch nicht, keine Ahnung. Hätte auch scheiße werden können. Ja, aber das ist genau der Punkt, nämlich die waren schon Fan, bevor der Film rauskam. Danach, Fan sein ist ja leicht, aber die waren schon, und deswegen wurden sie auch verewigt, der große Fanclub. Vielleicht haben die den Dreh auch irgendwie unterstützt durch Komparsen, keine Ahnung. Ja, ja, ja, das kann sein. Das kann sein. Ich weiß es nicht, aber das ... Die 501. Legion von Star Wars, so eine Sturmtruppenlegion, die haben ja auch bei Mandalorian mitgemacht. Und weil die halt wahnsinnig coole Kostüme haben und mitbringen und dann auch sehr authentisch halt Sturmtruppen darstellen können. Deswegen haben die die dann benutzt. Was ja, wenn man das weiss, die Star-Wars-Fankultur ist ja so groß. Und bei den Prequels hat Josh Lucas einfach dann diese, gesagt, ne, Druidenarmee. Ja. Eine komplett animierte, ja, aber wir hatten heute Trittisch Leute, Fans, die das darstellen, nein, wir animieren das alles, niemand soll mitmachen. Nur ich, ich, ich und Jar Jar Binks, tausendmal Jar Jar Binks, die mit blauen Kugeln werfen, ja, aber gegen Laserwaffen, die werfen blaue Kugeln. Und wenn du mir noch einmal widersprichst, dann ist der gross, der ist ja Ober Jar Jar Binks, stottert und ist dick. Und macht immer ... Okay, ich höre ja schon auf. Noch einmal fragen, so, so, jetzt reicht's. Aber es ist ja auch spannend, für was es alles Fanclubs gibt. Ich schaue nämlich tatsächlich gerade eine fantastische ZDF-Doku, die ... Ja, die habe ich auch angefangen. Ja, und da geht es ... Die Doku heißt Der Maulwurf, Freunde von Kim Jong-Un. In der ZDF-Mediathek könnt ihr euch das anschauen, Undercover in Nordkorea. Und da geht es um Journalisten, die sich in Nordkorea einschleusen. und da geht es um diesen Dänen, der halt einfach in einen Nordkorea-Fanclub eintritt. Es gibt in Dänemark einen Nordkorea-Fanclub, der trifft sich und findet halt einfach Nordkorea gut und das ist alles. Aber alleine dann darüber dann in das Regime sich einen Maul wurfen zu können, ist ja auch geil, weil dann, ich dachte gerade die ganze Zeit, was für ein alberner Fanclub, also aber anscheinend doch nicht so albern, wenn man dadurch wirklich nach Nordkorea kommt. Ja, absolut, aber vor allem auch natürlich auch ein Zeichen, dass die nordkoreanische Regierung auf Fanclubs zugehen muss, weil sonst wirklich niemand vielleicht mit dem Land was zu tun hat. Die stehen alle in dem Propaganda-Film im Abspann. Und die sagen, ja, macht ruhig, aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine coole Idee. Und tolle Doku, ich habe es mir noch nicht ganz angeguckt, aber es ist auf jeden Fall immer toll. Aber ich verstehe es. Ich verstehe nicht, warum man da beitreten sollte, aber ich verstehe schon, dass das Land natürlich die Geheimhaltung und diese Mythik, das Mythos so fremd ist. Das kann schon interessant sein. Ja, schon so eine gewisse Ausschallkraft hat, also das verstehe ich schon. Ich mache mir halt einfach nur Sorgen, was Nordkorea angeht, dass die sich halt, dass die sich noch mal aufteilen. Weil wenn Nordkorea sich noch mal... Du meinst wegen der Bezeichnungen. Richtig, weil entweder sagst du dann Nordostkorea. Nordost und Nordwestkorea. Und Nordwestkorea. Und dann wird es halt einfach fucking albern, weil wenn Nordostkorea sagt, wir teilen uns auch noch mal, dann muss auch wieder irgendwann das internationale Gremium zusammenkommen und sagen, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, das wird gar nichts. Diese Schilder, die vor jedem Teilnehmer stehen, die haben eine gewisse Länge. Und du kannst nicht Nordwest-Südost-Korea da heißen. Das geht nicht. Ja, aber wenn sie die Schriftart kleiner machen. Nein, die sind genormt, die sind ja fest montiert.
Die kannst du ja nicht einfach wegnehmen, das ist ja kein Pappzettel oder so. Gut, dann habe ich eine Frage an Equatorial Guinea, weil das passt auch nicht drauf. Da steht Equatorial G-Punkt. Ja, da mussten wir extra ein zweites Schild installieren und da hat der Hausmeister gesagt, das machen wir nie wieder. Der hat mir ganz schön Einlauf gegeben und hat gesagt, das machen wir gefälligst nie wieder. Und deswegen, Herr Jong von Nord, Ost, West, Süd, Mittelkorea. Ja. Was war das eigentlich für ein Bullshit mit Mittelkorea? Wir haben uns verstritten. Da gab es so ein Buffet. Ja, das ist ja nicht mein Problem. Und er hat sich von der anderen Seite angestellt. Okay? Ja, okay, das können wir ja auch klären. Aber da nennt euch doch Jim Jiminy oder so. Das stimmt. Oder ein neuer Name für das Land. Das Problem ist jetzt auch, dazu kam ich noch nicht, wegen ihrer Hastierade, aber unsere Hauptstadt mussten wir auch trennen. Nein, hör auf. Pyongyang ist fucking so schwer auszusprechen. Es ist jetzt Nordwest. NeinNein. Unter-Rheinisch-Pyongyang. Nee, komm, komm. Nee, ich hab keinen Bock mehr. Ich hab keinen Bock mehr. Bomb die weg. Ist mir egal jetzt. Scheiß drauf. Bomb die alle weg. Das ist mir zu viel. Aber weißt du, ich hätt auch mal Bock wieder auf ein neues Land. Ach so, ich dachte jetzt um Krieg. Ich war froh, dass du nicht Krieg gesagt hast. Nee, ich hätte Bock, weil es gibt ja zum Beispiel ganz viele neue Firmen, immer Startups, irgendwie jetzt ganz viele Firmen, die irgendwie deine Einkäufe nach Hause tragen. Und dann denkt man sich, okay, cool Startup, wie machen die es anders, was ist da neu, was ist deren USP? Aber irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, so ein neues Land wäre auch mal wieder cool. Man sagt so, wir machen neu auf. Neue Leute, Startups, junge interessierte Leute, die Bock haben, machen ein neues Land und können dann auch mal so Dinge wieder neu erfinden. Problem eins, Fläche. Nee, Berg innen ins Wasser werfen, ja, kopfüber. Nein, ich habe nie Idee, ich kombiniere jetzt Probleme und mache sie zu Lösungen. Gut, nicht schlecht, oder? Ja. Den ganzen Müll, der im Ozean ist, wird zu einer großen, wird aufgehäuft. Gepresst. Gepresst, um dann eine Landform im Ozean, mitten im Ozean, wo das Klima cool ist, das Klima immer so 25 Grad hat, aufgehäuft. Und dann drüber einfach nur Beton und Gras. Das könnte ja das erste mobile Land sein. Was rumschwimmt. Du machst da einfach so einen 9-PS-Motor unten dran und dann knattern die da durch die Gegend. Und dann wird die in den USA irgendwie zu rechts und so und dann sagen die Tschau. Aber können wir... Und fahren dann langsam rüber nach Europa. Oder die haben so einen leistungsstarken Motor, dass die immer unter der Sonne fahren. Immer Tag. Das ist auch scheiße. Immer Tag. Vielleicht länger Tag. Und dann in der Nacht fahren die wieder zurück. Und tagsüber fahren die mit der Sonne mit und nachts wieder ein Stück zurück. Sodass die wirklich 15 Stunden Sonne haben den ganzen Tag. Ich finde es erst mal super, wenn die vor Regen wegfahren könnten.
Ja, kein Problem.
Also vor Regen, Tag und Nacht finde ich gut, wie es ist.
Also okay, ich finde es interessant, dass du ein Problem lösen willst, wo wir uns als Menschen schon ganz gut drauf eingestellt haben. Also ich finde, vor Regen wegfahren finde ich super, vor Winter wegfahren finde ich super, von der Erde weg finde ich auch im Zweifel gut.
Vielleicht macht man es, vielleicht ist es das erste komplett, naja, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, Basisdemokratische Land, wollte ich sagen. Und zwar kann jeder sich einen Motor kaufen und an der Küste den installieren und dann halt einfach fahren, wohin er will. Und dadurch hast du immer die Gesamtmeinung des Landes, die meisten wollen nach, die 80 Prozent wollen nach rechts, 20 nach links, also fahren wir relativ langsam. Prinzip Twitch. Also, meine Idee für das Land als Staatsform wäre Twitch. Twitchism. Twitchism heißt das Land. Twitchism, nee, Twitchism Müllland heißt es. So, es ist halt auf Trash gebaut. Okay. So, und obendrauf wohnen halt ganz viele Menschen. So, und die ganze Zeit läuft ein Chat.
So, und dann kannst du mit Ausrufezeichen Norden dafür abstimmen.
Oh ja, stimmt.
Und es ist halt ...
Genau, du brauchst nur einen Motor, du brauchst nur eine Schraube.
Einen Motor, und je nachdem, wo die Mehrheit immer hinfahren will, fährt das hin.
Ja, das kann ich.
Das heißt, und der Chat, und das kannst du über alle Sachen machen,
du kannst auch Ausrufezeichen Rot-Grün abstimmen, dann wird eine rot-grüne Regierung gelegt. Okay, ja. Also alles wird die ganze Zeit mit diesem Chat, der die ganze Zeit läuft. Ich dachte jetzt, wenn du vor der Ampel stehst und sagst, das nervt. Grün. Ausrufezeichen Grün? Nee, dann kannst du Ausrufezeichen Ampeln weg. Und wenn es keine Stimmen findet, dann werden Ampeln abgeschafft. Ausrufezeichen Kreisverkehr. Okay, okay. Finde ich gut. Also wir haben ein bewegliches Land, aber da fände ich es interessant, weil gibt es denn auch so einen Geschenkkorb, wenn du ein neues Land machst? Also kommen dann die anderen Länder und sagen, herzlich willkommen. Und dann, weil ich denke mir, also zum Beispiel, ich stelle mir so vor, dass wenn du ein Startup machst, dann gibt es immer so die erste Phase Traum, Traum, Huhu, Garage. Aber irgendwann kommt dann so ein Typ, der sagt, so läuft's, so läuft das Business. Und der kennt sich aus, der hat schon mal eine Firma gehabt und der erklärt ihm das. Irgendwann kommt halt Justin Timberlake von Napsack. Genau, kommt Justin Timberlake und sagt, ich habe schon mal eine Firma gegründet. Und ist es bei Ländern auch so, dass man so ein paar Anfängerfehler vorbeugt und so du mit deinem neuen Start-up-Land so, ja, wir dachten uns jetzt die Hymne in F-Moll. Und dann kommt so die, ne, und das ist nicht. Kleiner, kleiner Tipp, kleiner Tipp, ihr könnt machen, geil, geile Idee, ihr könnt machen, was ihr wollt, aber kleiner Tipp von mir, bleibt bei C-Uhr. Es ist, wir haben, wir haben, it's singable, it's singable. Ja, it's singable. Und die Amerikaner sagen dann so, vertraut uns, trust me, our anthem is not singable. Ja, so it's in F minor, it's in F minor, c major. Und dann zwinkern die mit dem amerikanischen Kaugummi, lächeln. Ja, einfach so ein paar Anfängerfehler vermeiden. Und wir dachten uns, wir machen einen König. Ja, und Frankreich so eine kurze Anekdote. Anekdote, lasst mich eine kurze Geschichte erzählen. Und Deutschland schon so, oh Gott, here we go again, wie die Deutschen sagen.
Okay, kein König, dann vielleicht einen Diktat.
Ah, jetzt komm ich.
Ist Nordkorea so?
Warum nicht?
Nord-West-Süd-Korea sagt, nein, nie wieder Diktatur.
Hä? Wir dachten, ihr seid eine Diktatur.
Nein, das war Nord-West-Süd-Süd-Süd-Süd-Süd-Süd-Süd-Korea.
Die sind Diktatur. Hä? Wir dachten, ihr seid eine Diktatur. Nein, das war Norden, Süd, Süd, Süd, Süd, Süd. Wir hassen Süd, Süd, Südkorea. Die sind Diktaturen. Wir sind ein Land des Volkes. Wir sind ein Land des Volkes. Okay, gut, ja, ja, okay, haben wir schon. Kleiner Pfandfeld am Rande, um jetzt von diesem Quatsch mal wegzukommen. Okay. Deutschland verkauft, glaube ich, sogar mal, verkaufen wir nicht sicher, aber jedenfalls muss man sich vorstellen, dass das Steuersystem von Deutschland als Franchise in andere Länder schon bereits etabliert wurde. Ja, ein Drittel der ... Ja, stimmt eigentlich, es muss ja nicht jedes Land sich selber hinsetzen und ein Steuersrecht schreiben. Nee, genau, und ich glaube, die Verfassung und so ist ja einigermassen modern im geschichtlichen Kontext, und deswegen wurde die auch schon ein paar Mal verscherbelt an andere kleinere Länder. Aber was kostet das? Das System ist halt wahnsinnig gut. Und ich glaube nicht, dass Deutschland gut darin ist, das zu vermarkten. Ich glaube, die geben das denen einfach. Aber Trash Island ruft jetzt im Außenministerium an und sagt, hallo, braucht ihr eure Verfassung noch? Nee, erst mal hat Trash Island eine eigene Sprache. Noch nicht. Wir können uns noch nicht einigen. Wir haben eine Menge Ausrufezeichen, Ideen für Sprachen. Noch sind wir offen. Aber können wir mal kurz eure, wir wollen nur kurz eure Verfassung anschauen. Nur mal kurz, können wir kurz mal reingucken? Okay. Können wir, okay. Und dann so, rrrt, rrrt, tippt wer dessen hastig in sein Handy.
Reißt jede Seite raus.
Rrrt.
Was machen die da?
Rrrt, nichts.
Rrrt, tippt, wer dessen hast du in sein Handy. Reißt jede Seite raus. Was machen Sie da? Nichts. Rrrt. Und wie ist es mit Steuern bei euch? Können wir da mal reingucken? Ja, mit sein muss ich hier. Okay, danke schön. Und dann kommt so eine Piep, Piep, so eine Wagenladung. Weil ein Drittel der Weltliteratur über Steuern, habe ich schon mal erzählt, glaube ich, sind in deutscher Sprache verfasst. Ein Drittel der Weltliteratur übersteuern. Sagt man da Literatur? Ja, über jedes, also ein Drittel geschriebenes Wort der Welt übersteuern ist in deutscher Sprache verfasst. Like they know. Und deswegen glaube ich, da würde ich mich auch in Deutschland halten. Aber ich meine, da muss es doch Lizenzrechte geben, oder? Wenn du das Steuersystem oder die Verfassung von Deutschland kaufst, dann sag ich doch mal, Moment mal, ihr habt jetzt schon mal, also eure Verfassung ist schon sehr ähnlich. In welchem Maßstab gilt denn Urheberrecht? Weil gilt Urheberrecht auch für Geschichte? Ja, weil technisch gesehen macht ja Trash Island alles, was die einnehmen an Steuern, ist ja durch die Verfassung eigentlich. Das heißt, die machen ja Geld mit dem Land. Die machen Geld mit Deutschland. Und Geld mit der deutschen Verfassung. Also eigentlich könnte man da Ansprüche erheben und sagen, Entschuldigung, Trash Islands. Nur weil ihr zwei Kommata durch Semikolons ersetzt habt, ist das immer noch unsere Verfassung. Und Trash Island. Hey, hey! Trash Island hat sich den Mittelfinger ausgestreckt und fährt weg, langsam in Richtung Amerika. Die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar, Semikolon. Das ist anders. Fragezeichen. Fragezeichen, Ausrufezeichen. Unsinnenfremde. Oder einfach alles in Fragen formulieren. Ist die Würde des Menschen nicht unantastbar? Sollte die Würde des Menschen nicht unantastbar sein? Bisschen snappy. Bisschen snappy, auch viel in Limerick-Form, viel gereimt. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Aber ist doch, also ich meine, es wird doch langfristig so kommen.
Aber darf man das denn?
Ich habe so eine geile Website gefunden.
Website-Tipp der Woche, hast du Bock?
Website-Tipp der Woche.
Los geht's!
Der Website-Tipp der UFO-Podcast.
Ich weiss nicht, wie sie heisst, aber da kann man sich simulieren lassen, wie die Welt aussieht, wenn die Gletscher wegschmelzen und die Polarkappen wegschmelzen und der Meeresspiegel steigt um ein Meter, zwei Meter, drei Meter, vier Meter. Wir haben das ein bisschen zu fun angekündigt. Und wie viele Leute dadurch dann weg müssen und sterben werden und ganze Länder sind überschwemmt, die sind weg. Und das ist echt furchteinflößend, weil wir alle wissen ja, die Marmande wird nicht mehr aufgehalten und kommt. Und damit kannst du dir angucken, welche Länder alle abhauen. Und dadurch gibt es ja eine Menge Menschen, die irgendwo anders leben müssen. Aber ist Trash Island sich eine geniale Idee? Ja, Trash Island macht die Pforten auf und sagt, ihr müsst halt ... Macht die stinkenden Pforten auf. Ihr müsst halt ... Wir legen halt zwischen 14 und 14.20 Uhr hier an. Wenn ihr da seid, kommt an Bord, wenn nicht, sind wir weg. Und die fahren einmal auf Klügeltour durch die ganze Welt. Und sammeln Leute ein. Und sammeln alle ein, die im Wasser sind, und ziehen die raus und machen ein neues Land auf. Ist ohne Scheiß nicht Trash Island die Lösung? Einfach die Lösung. Neue Landmasse im Ostfern. Und du bist beweglich. Weil wenn es jetzt irgendwie heißt, oh nein, vor allem ein schwimmendes Land ist ja das Beste, was du machen kannst, weil du im Wohnen bist gegen ... Der ist für dich so das USP. Ja, absolut. Der ist für dich so das Krasse. Der ist für mich gar nicht so wichtig. Aber es ist doch logisch weitergedacht, wenn du sagst, oh, der Meeresspiegel steigt, lass uns auf einem schwimmenden Land leben, weil da kann der Meeresspiegel 150 Kilometer steigen, hunderte, tausende Meter hoch. Aber ist auf Wasser nicht noch eins schlechter als auf Sand? Wenn man sagt, das Haus ist auf Sand gebaut, ist schon schlecht. Wenn man sagt, das Haus ist auf Müll, das auf Wasser schwimmt gebaut. Das ist auf Sand, auf Müll, auf Wasser gebaut, sagt dann nicht jeder Architekt, ne. Aber kann man den Müll nicht nutzen, weil du hast ja da zum Beispiel auch ganz viele Joghurtbecher, wo noch ein bisschen drin ist. Das heisst, wenn du da jetzt auf Trash Island Pflanzen anbaust, dann saugen die ja mit ihren Wurzeln, gehen die in den Müll und saugen da nochmal irgendwie den Frupp raus, so dass du total gute Pflanzen hast, wo der Frupp drin ist. Das ist doch genial. Ich glaube, das ist ein wahnsinnig fruchtbares Land. Und vor allem auch Wasser, aber ja. Öl ist ja tote Dinosaurier, aus denen wird Plastik gemacht. Wie ein IQ-Test. Jedes Öl sind tote Dinosaurier. Genau. Alle Dinosaurier sind tot, es gibt unendlich viel Öl. Also gibt es kein lebendes Öl. Fertig. Und wenn du jetzt aber sagst, wir machen Land aus Plastik, was ja auch Öl ist, Kann es ja gut sein, dass in 100, 200 Jahren du das wieder abpumpen kannst als frisches Öl. Wie so ein Kompost. Wie ein Kompost. Wie ein schöner Kompost. Wie ein Plastik-Kompost. Das gefällt mir immer besser. Am Ende entsteht doch einfach Bespin, oder? Am Ende entsteht doch der Gasplan. Die Gasplanstadt in Star Wars. Ja, das ist doch das Ende vom Lied Lied ist doch sowas. Eine fliegende Stadt. Eine fliegende Stadt. Aber das ist der Alte, Mann. Fliegende können nicht fliegen. Da hört es auf. Die Städte können nicht fliegen. Das ist wie auf Luft gebaut. Jetzt wird es lächelig. Jetzt wird es Alba. Da hört der Sprichwörter. Es gibt keine dusseligen Sprichwörter. Ich finde es ohne Scheiß, dass fast die Lösung der Problematik. Vor allem, dann können wir einfach mal sagen, vor allem Trashtown kauft Müll. Das ist übrigens in einer Mad Max Welt. Die brauchen ja mehr Land. Trashtown! Das heißt, sie fahren nach Trashtown! Oder Garbageville, je nachdem wie. Garbageville! Also da gibt es dann verschiedene Stadtteile und die kaufen anderen Ländern den Müll ab, weil die brauchen ja Müll, um grösser zu werden. Das heißt, die anderen Länder können ihren Müll verkaufen, produzieren dadurch noch viel mehr Müll. Jetzt gibt mir eine Sekunde, alle Länder ausser Trashtown produzieren ganz viel Müll.
Und können wir kurz Werbung machen?
Ja, können wir wirklich.
Jedenfalls habe ich diesen Film geguckt, den ich nicht mehr genau erinnern kann.
Aber das ist schon gemein. Aber vor allem auch der Regisseur kann sich vielleicht nicht daran erinnern, dass er den Film je gemacht hat. Einfach so, niemand weiß, alle, die in dem Film mitgespielt haben, haben ihn vergessen, der Regisseur den vergessen. Es ist wirklich so ein Geisterfilm. Was habe ich 1986 gemacht? Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich weiß es aber auch nicht. Ich habe so eine riesen Lücke. Ich war ein paar Jahre... Ich habe eine 90-minütige Lücke
in meinem Lebenslauf. Irgendwas
war da. Wenn es den Mandela-Effekt
gibt und alle Menschen
glauben, Nelson Mandela
sei in den 80ern in Gefangenschaft
gestorben, gibt es dann auch
Filme, an die sich alle Menschen
falsch erinnern oder so Filmenden
oder einen Film, an den sich alle
Menschen nicht erinnern. Ja, das stimmt, oder halt einen Film, an den sich Leute erinnern, den es gar nicht gibt. Das wäre ja spannend. Weil, dass Leute Filme falsch erinnern, okay, weil Autoren sind ja auch manchmal nicht perfekt. Pretty Woman gibt es nicht. Pretty Woman gibt es einfach. Doch, klar, habe ich doch gesehen. Nein, gibt es nicht. Nein, google it, es gibt Pretty Woman nicht. Doch, und dann wissen auch alle die Storygrope. Ja. Sie fragen, wie viele Menschen müssen es glauben, dass es den gibt, bis es ihn dann gibt. Oder bei deinem Film ist der Mandela-Effekt andersrum. Es gibt ihn, aber niemand hat ihn gesehen oder niemand kann sich an ihn erinnern. Das ist so umgedreht. Umgedrehter Mandela-Effekt. Also der ist schon da und die Leute sagen, den gibt's doch nicht. Doch, da ist er. Nein, die DVD ist nicht beschrieben. Doch, ist sie, hier leg sie ein. Da kommt ja gut, Studio-Logo, toll. Wie lange willst du es leugnen? Da kommt doch nichts mehr. Naja, mein Gott, da ist vielleicht einer kurz was gefehlt. Eine Szene macht doch keinen Film. Meine Gott, der erste Akt, das schreibe ich dir in dem Nachmittag, ist doch kein Film. Mein Gott, nur wenn du einen Abspann hast am Ende, macht es doch zu keinem Film. Wollen wir mal einen 24-Stunden-Drehbuchmarathon machen? Wir schreiben 24 Drehbücher? Nein. Nein, wo wir in einem Tag, wo wir in 24 Stunden, wir streamen uns live auf Twitch in deinem Wohnzimmer. Stellst du eine Kamera auf? Warum in meinem Wohnzimmer?
Genau, bei mir machen.
Wann?
Eine Kamera aufstellen nächste Woche.
Und wir und 24 Stunden können uns Leute beobachten.
Und wir schreiben in diesen 24 Stunden mit dem Twitch-Chat zusammen einen Film.
Aber wir brauchen Warner Brothers am Hörer.
Warner Brothers, die Leitung steht.
Warner Brothers auf laut. Alle drei. Wie viele gibt's? Chip, Chap und Ronald. Alle am Telefon sind, also wir haben, drei Handys liegen auf dem Tisch. Es sieht folgendermaßen aus. Du sitzt ganz rechts, ich sitze ganz links, in der Mitte drei Telefone, dahinter eine riesige weiße Wand mit diesen Storykarten, wo dann so Storypoints dranhängen, die wir wild rumschieben. Ja. Und wir beide am Handy. Wir beide am Handy-Gehrenszeit und sind gelangweilt. Ich fände es cool, wir schreiben in 24 Stunden ein Drehbuch. Und danach wird es vorgelesen. Danach wird es mit verteidigten Rollen und Schauspielern in diesem Podcast hier vorgelesen. Am Ende des Streams oder hier? Oder am Ende des Streams kommen dann noch mal Promis. Kommt Katjana Gerz rein, Alexander Wipprecht. Uli Welke sehe ich da, Alexander Wipprecht. Internationale Stars, die anwesend sind. Dua Lipa zum Beispiel. D je nachdem, wer halt gerade da ist, guckt man kurz vorbei. Caterer 2. Und spielt Guy with Glasses. Guy with Glasses 3. Ja. Ich fände es nicht schlecht. Aber können wir uns einigen? Können wir uns einigen? Nein, aber das ist ja der Spaß. Die letzten Folgen hier haben wir jeweils pro Folge einen Film,
mindestens einen Film gepischt.
Wie viele Warner Brothers haben uns angerufen, um die uns abzukaufen?
Zero.
Keiner.
Niemand, nichts.
Kein Brother.
Kein Mensch, no brother.
No brother hat uns angerufen.
No brother hat uns angerufen, um uns die Ideen aus der Hand zu reißen.
Also vielleicht ...
Ist Warner Brothers noch in Brüderhand?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es mittlerweile schon Warner Nephews heißt. Ich weiss es gar nicht, ob man es eigentlich umbenennen müsste. Ja, wir müssen uns nicht umbenennen. Ich weiss es nicht. Und wie viele gab es überhaupt? Oh, ey Stefan, ich hab ... Aber vor allem, das Tolle ist ja, man muss ja heutzutage eigentlich nichts mehr selber machen, weil wir haben die Technologie und ich habe letztens etwas gefunden, was mir eine solche Freude bereitet hat.
Und ich hoffe dir auch. Und zwar bin ich eingestiegen in die wunderbare Welt der Zufallsgeneratoren. Ja, die wunderbare Welt der Zufallsgeneratoren und es ist ein Traum, denn ich bin gestossen auf Buchtitelgenerator. Und das war, also das war ein Nachmittag, ich hatte wirklich, meine Rippen haben geschmerzt, ich habe laut gelacht, ich habe geweint vor Lachen, weil die Vorstellung, dass das echte Bücher sind, die Leute lesen, mit den zufällig generierten Buchtiteln, war ein absoluter Traum. Aber das ist doch super. Und zwar, so beginnt nämlich dann unser 14-Stunden-Drehbuchmarathon, beginnt mit einem Klick auf Filmnamengenerator und dann alles basiert dann darauf. Wie ein Improf-Argent. Ja, wir können ja schon ein bisschen üben. Du kannst mir ja schon mal ein bisschen die Logline, die Zusammenfassung folgender Bücher zeigen. Und zwar habe ich folgendes gemacht. Ich habe zwei Zufallsgeneratoren kombiniert. In Reihe oder in Reihe geschaltet? Nicht parallel geschaltet. Ich habe einmal zufälliger Buchtitel und dann geschrieben von zufälliger Name generiert. Das heißt, hier ist die Spiegel-Bestsellerliste der zehn Bücher mit Autoren ... Können wir den Twitter-Account machen, bitte, der jeden Tag eine Top-Ten raushaut mit random Stuff? Ja, oder, genau, random Buchtitel von random Namen. Also, auf Platz Nummer zwei der Spiegel-Bestsellerliste, auf Platz Nummer zehn haben wir das Buch Heisere Hummeln von Manfred Kresse. Also Manfred Kresse, erst mal kennen die der Manfred Kresse. Nach seinen Hits, erst mal, also ich dachte, es kann nach Heitere Bienen nicht mehr weiterkommen, aber dann kam Heisere Hummeln. Heisere Hummeln. Ich glaube, auch das sind zwei Wörter, die wurden noch nie zusammenverwendet, noch nie in der Geschichte der Menschheit. Aber wir lachen, aber es ist ja ein sehr trauriger Roman. Ja, es ist eigentlich ein Drama. Es ist ja eine Metapher. Er verarbeitet ja auch den Tod seiner gesamten Familie in diesem Buch. Seiner gesamten Familie und Freunde in dem Buch. Es heißt ja, wenn man das Gefühl hat, dass selbst die Hummeln umherum heiser sind, dann nimmt man die Welt ja so grau und traurig und trist wahr, dass es ja quasi nicht mehr weitergehen kann. Wenn einem selbst Hummeln keine Freude mehr bereiten können. Das ist ein Buch über Depressionen, das ist ein Buch über Trauma, wie man mit Trauma klarkommt, das ist ein Buch über Verlust und aber Rühren. Können Sie kurz was zur Geschichte sagen, Herr Kresse?
Also es spielt in Norwegen, in einem kleinen Fischert-und-Fischertorf in Norwegen, wo ein Imker wohnt. Ja. Aber ungeachtet seines Berufes hat er bei einem tragischen Bootsunglück auf hoher See, auf einem Fjord, hoher Seegang im Fjord, hat er dann leider Gottes seine gesamte Familie und Freunde verloren.
Rauchen Sie die Taschen noch, Sie schwitzen sehr stark. Ist es die Emotion?
Nee, ja, es ist die Emotion. Und es ist ein bisschen autobiografisch, deswegen nimmt es mich ein bisschen mit. Und dann versucht er halt damit klarzukommen, alleine in seiner kleinen Holzhütte. Und geht immer wieder zu seinen Bienen und Hummeln in seinem Garten. Er hält Hummeln. Er hält Hummeln, ja. Auch Bienen, aber mehr Hummeln. Aber wird er auch nicht von den Hummeln gehalten? Nee, das ist ja dann der große Plotwist. Irgendwann hat er dann so ein Haus und dann baut er an alle Hummeln kleine Bindfäden, bindet die fest und es sind so viele Hummeln, dass das Haus wegfliegt. Aber ein Junge, ein kleiner Junge ist noch im Haus. Gut, okay. Klingt nach einem tollen Story. Kommen wir zu Platz Nummer neun. Hermann Kresse.
Mein Name ist Hermann Manfred Kresse. Das habe ich gehört, ja.
Zu Platz Nummer neun der
Spiegelbesterliste der zufälligen Titel.
Ein absoluter Favorit, und zwar
auf Platz Nummer neun Die Hauptnichte.
Die Hauptnichte von Margarete Top.
Margarete Top? Margarete Top. Mit zwei P, Die Hauptnichte. Die Hauptnichte von Margarethe Topp. Margarethe Topp? Margarethe Topp mit zwei P die Hauptnichte. Die Hauptnichte. Die Hauptnichte. Auch ein Wort bisher noch nicht geäußert in der Geschichte der Menschheit.
Aber jetzt entwickelt sich ein anderes Format, und zwar wir beide, die quasi das literarische Quartett neu auferlegen, zu Titeln, die es nicht gibt.
Wir besprechen, die es nicht gibt. Das ist geil.
Und zwar ist es das literarische, fiktionische Quartett neu auferlegen. Ja, wir sprechen Bücher, die es nicht gibt. Wir besprechen Bücher, die es nicht gibt. Das ist geil. Und zwar ist es das literarische, fiktionale Quartett. Jede Woche haben wir zwei neue Gäste. Spotify, hört uns. Genau, du bist ja zu viert und die haben ja auch immer, jeder hat ein Buch vorgestellt, also den Plot kurz. Und jeder stellt ein Buch vor. Genau, aber alle haben es gelesen, in Anführungszeichen, und können dazu was sagen. Also mir hat die Hauptnichte gar nicht gefallen. Also ich finde es ein unglaublich langweiliges Buch. Ich meine, wenn sich hier Frau Top rausnimmt, 800 Seiten über ein Thema zu schreiben, so dann denke ich mir, da muss es auch unterhaltsam sein. Naja, aber sie müssen ja natürlich auch die Untertöne lesen. Also natürlich, wenn man den Roman oberflächlich betrachtet, dann die Story ist platt, das ist klar. Die Story ist platt, ja, fassen Sie so kurz zusammen. Da bin ich absolut bei Ihnen, die Story ist platt. Wir haben diese Franziska, die aufwächst auf dem Hof, die dann auf diese wilde Reise geht. Das ist platt, das haben wir schon gelesen. Der Subtext, aber die sexuelle Emanzipation, die da immer mitschwingt, die fand ich sehr packend. Ich finde, da haben Sie ein bisschen viel reininterpretiert. Für mich ist die Hauptnichte ein blutleerer Roman, der mehr Selbstzweck ist. Einfach, klar kann sie schön schreiben, darum geht es ja gar nicht. Natürlich schreibt sie wunderschön bildlich, bunt, man hat Bilder im Kopf. Aber sie will hier Thomas Mann sein. Die Szene in der Telefonzelle. Es gibt Highlights, sie war lustig, aber das ist zu wenig. Das reicht für mich nicht, um die Hauptnichte hier in dem Umfang zu besprechen.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum sie das Buch mitgenommen haben.
Ich fände es Zeitverschwendung.
Sehr hartes Urteil zu die Hauptnichte von Margarethe Topp.
Vielleicht kann die Autorin auch selber anwesend sein.
Vielleicht wäre das auch was, weiß ich nicht.
Wir kommen weiter zu Platz Nummer acht, Platte Tüte.
Platte Tüte war lustig. Platte Tüte von Elvira Wohlraab. Platte Tüte ist ein Poproman, ist ein schmutziger, dreckiger Szeneroman. Irgendwie auch mal was zum Schmunzeln, was zum Lachen, viel persönliche Anekdoten, viel vierte Wanddurchbrochen. Das Milieu, finde ich, wird auf eine Art gezeigt. Es ist eine Milieübesprechung. Es ist eine Milieustudio und es ist aber auch ein sehr persönliches Buch. Also ich glaube, das ist wie wenn einem Freunde eine Geschichte erzählen, die man nur lustig findet, wenn man dabei war. So fühlt man sich, wenn man diese Romanen hat. Man war dabei. Man war in gewisser Weise dabei, aber es ist auch keine epochale Story, es ist kein Meisterwerk. Sie haben Thomas Mann angesprochen. Aber das will es ja gar nicht sein. Nein, wenn das will, ist nicht sein. Es ist etwas, das man bei Bier und Brezeln zu Hause nacherzählen kann. Da ist mir was Lustiges passiert. Und ich finde, also Elvira Wohlrapp, stilistisch, natürlich, sie ist kein... Ihr Debütroman. Ja, sie ist keine hohe Dichterin. Ich freue mich auf dich. Aber sie hat eine Leichtigkeit, eine Spritzigkeit, die ich in ihren Zeilen finde, die mir so gefallen hat. Und die durch diesen Roman tragen wie ein frischer Wind. Also ich fand es ganz toll. Ich fand es ganz toll. Und es ist ja vor allem, das habe ich so auch noch nicht gelesen. Nein, das liest man selbst. Dieses Dahergeschriebene und dann doch auch noch alte Techniken, die Montagetechnik, ja angewandt, um hier quasi auch ab und zu von Zeit losgelöst in die verschiedenen einzelnen Momente der Charaktere zu springen. Das fand ich schön. Es ist ein Buch gewordener Streich. Es ist ein April-Scherz, der hier zu Papier gebracht wurde. Platte Tüte von Elvira vorgebracht. Ist ein Tipp, die gibt es im 990 Euro im Fischer Verlag erschienen. Können wir nur empfehlen. Ganz toll. Jetzt kommen wir natürlich zu der genauen Gegenseite, nämlich mit der Büffel von Helmut Petermann. Eine ganz andere Farbe, die wir hier haben. Der Büffel, ja. Und Sie sind ja ein Petermann-Kenner, glaube ich, kann man sagen. Ja, ich kenne ihn sogar persönlich, also ich habe ihn irgendwann Ende der 80er Jahre mal selbst kennengelernt in Konstanz. Und der Büffel ist für mich tatsächlich sein bestes Werk. Jetzt habe ich mir die Frage gestellt, wie bereite ich mich auf die Sendung vor, wie bringe ich den Zuschauern der Büffel nahe. Und ich glaube, das geht nicht. Das wird dem Büffel nicht gerecht. Es ist ein Werk, was man, glaube ich, lesen muss und was man erfahren muss. Ich glaube auch durchaus, dass man in 20 Jahren noch von der Büffel sprechen wird. Ach wirklich? Also Sie meinen, es überschattet die anderen Romane von Petermann? Es überschattet die anderen Romane, ja, im Positiven. Der Büffel ist, wenn man es kurz zusammenfasst, ein der buddendrucksartiger, wie eine Biografie geschrieben. Es beschreibt ganz gut diesen Fabrikbesitzer, der dann sich totbüffelt. Daher kommt ja, wie ich dann auch meine herauszulesen, die Pointe. Und er büffelt sich zu Tode. Und die ganze Familie, ob sie nun will oder nicht, muss nun mitmachen. Und es werden die wichtigen Fragen gestellt. Kapitalismus, zu welchem Preis? Aber ist es nicht auch sehr wulstig? Es ist wulstig, es ist klobig, aber ich finde durchaus, dass man es hier mit einem Werk zu tun hat, was man in, was, es wird Ihnen nicht gerade gerecht. Sie müssten doch am besten wissen, dass wir so ein Werk häufiger in dieser Sendung brauchen. Also für mich war der Büffel ein Berg. Es ist ein Berg, aber es lohnt sich, ihn zu erklimmen. Ich habe ihn erklommen, ich hatte Blasen an den Füssen und habe mir gedacht, hätte ich auch die Sahl mal nehmen können. Kommen wir zu Platz Nummer sechs der Best-Sale-Liste mit einem ungewöhnlichen Roman, möchte ich sagen.
Autor Marlon Nerz, glaube ich, dürfte vielen ein Begriff sein. Er stellt seinen neuen Roman vor, Welche Motte?
Für Tiere.
Eine sehr tierische Ausgabe. Marlon Nerz, welche Motte? Marlon Nerz ist übrigens ein Meganame. Sorry. Aber ich glaube, zu dem Roman wurde schon so viel gesagt, da können wir der Regaliter geben. Da brauchen wir jetzt nichts weiter. Beschäftigen wir lieber mit Platz Nummer fünf, obskure Nachrichten, schlotternde Rinden von Leonadina Roch. Erstmal, alle, also ich finde die Namen sind fantastisch in dieser Sendung. Können Sie den Titel nochmal? Das ist Obskure Nachrichten, Schlotternde Rinden. Also ein Titel, der natürlich direkt ein Bild aufmacht, das ist klar. Leonadina Roch hat hier, würde ich sagen, mit Worten ein Bild gemalt. Wie hat sie das geschafft? Sie hat es geschafft, also das ist stilistisch ganz interessant, was hier passiert. Nicht nur hat sie keinen wirklichen Protagonisten und es ist mehr ein Sachbuch gewordener fiktionaler Roman, nein, sie schafft es auch die modernen Fragen. Schlotternde Rinden, natürlich Klimawandel, klingt hier an, die Erde, die Angst hat, die Menschheit abschütteln will quasi. Und dass hier quasi auch die Gedanken des Baumes, die teilweise hier ja fast albern anklingen, fast dadaistisch wird hier mit stumpfen Waffen gekämpft. Also, es lässt sich wirklich sagen, dass das schon so ist. Es ist ein Perspektivenwechsel. Es ist ein Perspektivenwechsel. Sie fängt ja damit an, wie der Mensch Angst vor der Natur hat, der Bär, der Wolf, der Säbelzahntiger, wendet das Blatt aber über die Erzählung hinweg zu, die Natur hat Angst vor dem Menschen. Ist das nicht die Art, wie wir die heutige Welt sehen können? Nicht die Natur bedroht uns, sondern wir sind eher das Raubtier, das hier, das Beutetier, Natur reisst? Die Frage ist nur, ist es nicht alles ein bisschen platt? Ist das, was in dem Buch angesprochen wird, klar, ist die Liste spannend, aber ist die Frage nicht platt, ist die Quintessenz nicht platt, ich wringe den Lappen aus und am Ende habe ich kein Glas voll? Nein, also es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so platt wie platte Tüte, ich glaube, da sind wir uns alle einig, aber es ist natürlich auch auf eine Art geschrieben, es richtet sich jetzt nicht an Kinder, aber an Jugendliche ganz klar, also dieser Titel ist ja ein Meme quasi und richtet sich damit an die Generation, die dieses Problem tragen werden muss. Denn uns kann scheißegal sein, bin wir mal ehrlich. Gut, kommen wir also zu Platz vier. Der neue Roman, er schreibt ja jedes Jahr eins, Günther Ronellenfitsch legt sein neues Werk vor. Und zwar hat er geschrieben, unsere beschissene Küste des Steins, schreibt er, Günther Ronellenfitsch mit unsere beschissene Küste des Steins. Ja, und wie man es von Rundlein erwartet, auch wieder der übliche Page-Turner, den man kennt.
Spannend.
Aber es ist sicherlich spannend, aber er schreibt jedes Jahr eins.
Und die Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, ist diese Schlagzeile denn überhaupt dem Inhalt noch zuträglich? Also für mich ist es nicht mehr als eine, ja, bösformulierte Klolektüre. Ronel Fitch, finde ich, hat sich da selber in eine Sackgasse manövriert. Er ist so bekannt mittlerweile für seine Twists, für seine überraschenden Enden, dass man es mittlerweile erwartet, er hat ja mit seinen letzten drei Romanen versucht, diese Erwartungshaltung noch mal zu brechen, aber auch die Brechung ist mittlerweile eingepreist irgendwo, dass man eigentlich mehr oder weniger schon weiß, was passieren könnte, was er macht, man kennt seinen Stil. Ist ein Plottwist, den man erwartet, noch ein Plottwist? Ich meine, für dahergelaufene meine Mutter, Krimi-Fan, die kann das lesen, hat jetzt keine großen Ansprüche an ihre Lektüre. Es ist eine leicht zu böttige Lektüre, sicherlich spannend, sicherlich gut geschrieben, aber in der Fall hat mich hier nicht überzeugt. Kommen wir in die Top 3 und wir kommen zu meinem Lieblingsroman dieser Woche, dieser Liste, und zwar Ihr Elch des Wurms von Arthur Jägel. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass wir noch Zeilen von Arthur Jägel lesen dieses Jahr, aber er hat ein Buch auf den Markt geworfen. Ich habe Arthur Jägel auch abgeschrieben, also er hätte auch lange nichts gemacht. Und dieses Jahr noch diesen Namen auf der Liste zu haben, hat mich persönlich berührt. Es war ein freudiges Wiedersehen auch für mich. Es ist ein alter Freund und mit Ihr Elch des Wurms jetzt ein Buch, das finde ich, man so nicht erwartet hätte.
Hätte man so nicht erwartet, war mir aber dann doch ein Stück weit. Erstmal, wir haben richtig viel gelesen diese Woche, also Respekt an uns beide. Ja, also ihr Elch des Wurms fand ich sehr düster. Es war traurig, es war tief, es war Gefühle, die man kennt, da klingen Gefühle an, die wir alle schon mal gefühlt haben, aber formuliert haben wir sie so noch nicht und auch noch nicht gelesen. Das schimmert aber, finde ich, auch eine starke Menschlichkeit durch. Also man hat ja oft mit diesen sehr wuchtigen Romanen, mit diesem quasi Literaturmoloch oft das Gefühl, dass man da in irgendwelche tieferen Grotten steigt und irgendwelche dämonischen Höllenkreise und man sich da in irgendwelche dämonischen Pandemonien von Dämonie hineinbegibt. Da bleibt mir die Menschlichkeit oft auch auf der Strecke. Und wenn man es ist, ist es nicht sogar ein bisschen fatalistisch, wenn man sich das Buch durchliest und man kommt am Ende zum gleichen Punkt wie die Hauptfigur, die sich ja dann auch umbringt. Fatalistisch hätte ich Ihnen zugestimmt, er gäbe es das letzte Kapitel nicht. Aber ist das letzte Kapitel nicht im Sinne, ist es so ernst gemeint? Das habe ich nämlich gefragt beim Lesen. Es kann quasi nicht ernst gemeint sein. Ist es als Antithese formuliert? Es muss anders, ergibt es keinen Sinn. Jägel ist ein extrem präziser Architekt, was Bücher angeht. Da ist keine Silbe an der falschen Stelle. Er komponiert das Buch durch. Er komponiert es durch, manchen zu viel, habe ich auch schon gelesen, der konstruierte Stil, die wilde Grammatik, die er teilweise annutzt. Ja, und Susanne Wölkers aus der Erfersette hat nicht so Unrecht geschrieben. Gut, ja, aber dass Sie und Jägel eine jahrzehntelange Fehler am Laufen haben, ist, glaube ich, der Öffentlichkeit auch nicht verborgen geblieben. Also da muss man das, glaube ich, als Präambel hier voransetzen. Und deswegen fand ich diesen Roman fantastisch, als sie ihn beendet haben. Sie haben mir geschrieben auf WhatsApp, holy shit und ... Holy shit und dann dieses Gif mit dem kleinen Baby, ja, mit dem Mindblow. Und Ähnliches dachte ich auch bei dem letzten Kapitel, wir wollen nicht zu viel vorausgreifen und wollen es nächste Woche nochmal besprechen, denn Arthur Jägel hat sich angekündigt, er wird zugeschaltet sein. Aus Teneriffa wird er uns in der Sendung begleiten. Kommen wir auf Platz zwei, ein kontroverser Roman, den Zoe Klopper hier vorlegt, und zwar legt sie vor Das Land der Tanten. Das Land der Tanten ist nach die Hauptnichte mein Lieblingsbuch. Das Land der Tanten hat mir viel Spaß gemacht. Es war ein Abenteuer. Es ist ein Kinderbuch, klar, aber das macht Spaß. Also wie die kleine Elisabeth, das muss man sich vorstellen, sich auf die Reise begibt in die verschiedenen Länder.
Und dann gibt es das Land der Onkels, es gibt das Land der Tanten, es gibt das Land der Nichten, es gibt das Land der Cousins. Und in jedem dieser Länder macht sie verschiedene Erfahrungen, die sinnbildlich stehen für die Erfahrungen, die wir mit unseren Verwandten machen und die wir alle sicherlich kennen. Für Kinder ganz toll, für Erwachsene aber auch, es ist ganz schön illustriert von Elisabeth Nörz, die hat die Illustration gemacht und das hat wirklich interessant gemacht und greifbar. Also ich habe es meiner Tochter vorgelesen und sie war hellauf begeistert. Die Botschaft ist natürlich toll, egal in der Welt, wohin du reist, du findest Verwandte. Ja, also der Mensch ist dem Menschen ein Verwandter, ein Freund, jeder in der Welt kann ein Onkel sein. Homo homini Freund est, amicus est.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Das finde ich toll. Die Aussage ist natürlich, ja, ein bisschen schal, aber trotzdem auch zeitlos. Und deswegen finde ich es toll, sie macht das mit einem herzerwärmenden Stil und deswegen sehr, sehr toll von Zoe Klopper hier das Land der Tanten. Auf Platz eins ein Urgestein, wie gesagt, sie ziert die Schlagzeilen des Landes seit Monaten mit ihrem Werk und zwar auf Platz Nummer eins natürlich ist es keine Überraschung, Linde Genicke, Wunde Kanten von Bärbel Gommes. Bärbel Gomez, Linde Genicke, Wunde Kanten, Linde Genicke, Wunde Kanten ist vielleicht das beste Buch, was bislang in diesem Jahr erschienen ist. Linde Genicke, Wunde Kanten ist herzergreifend, es ist traurig und es ist vor allem schön. Die Präzision ist mir aufgefallen. Diese Liebesgeschichte zwischen den beiden Frauen. Es geht bis ins Detail. Es geht so ins Detail. In fast schon schlüpfrige Details, kann man hier auch mal sagen, die aber finde ich mit einer gewissen Reife inszeniert werden. Nein, aber das gehört dazu. Nein, absolut. Das gehört dazu. Liebe ist doch auch erotisch. Liebe ist auch schlüpfrig. Natürlich, das gehört dazu. Man muss natürlich nur gucken, dass es nicht ins Pornografische abdriftet, was, wie ich finde, hier und da die Gefahr lauert. Man denkt, das, uh, wurde das nicht ... Das wegzulassen, würde der Liebe nicht ansatzweise gerecht werden. Nein, aber es ist eine Frage der Betrachtungsweise. Es ist eine Frage der Betrachtungsweise. Der menschliche Körper kann ein Kunstwerk sein oder billige Pornografie. Da sind wir uns ja einig. Die Frage ist, wo ist die Grenze? Und das finde ich, diesen Balanceakt macht Bärbel Gommes hier absolut virtuos und schlägt auf der Messerschneide ein Salto. Und ich finde, das ist hoch gelungen, was sie macht, bis auf die letzte Seite wandert sie auf diesem schmalen Grat wie eine Behändetänzerin. Wie eine Behändetänzerin, das trifft es sehr gut, da sind wir alle auch bei einer Meinung. Na endlich mal! Aber Bärbel Gommis ist dir wirklich ein Meister gelungen. Und ich kann nur jedem dieses Buch empfehlen. Eine fantastische Liebesgeschichte. Und wir wollen nicht zu viel beraten, aber das letzte Kapitel ist mit das Traurigste, was uns jetzt hier reifend ist, was ich hier gelesen habe. Das stimmt. Wir freuen uns auf nächste Woche. Wir haben ganz tolle Romane nächste Woche. Zehn neue Romane nächste Woche. Sie haben zehn neue Romane gelesen für nächste Woche. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass Sie mit dabei waren. Wir haben kein Privatleben. Jetzt wünschen wir Ihnen ganz viel Spaß beim Lesen. Hoffentlich war da auch was für Sie dabei. Und wir hoffen, dass Sie die Literatur auch weiterhin genießen können, so wie wir bis nächste Woche. Bleiben Sie neugierig. Bleiben Sie neugierig. Ja, das waren zehn Titel Zufall generiert. Das waren 90 Titel, die wir besprochen haben. Ja, Wahnsinn. Also da sind so viele tolle Ideen drin, die man glaube ich schreiben kann. Alles freigegeben an der Stelle, kann alles geschrieben werden, schnappt euch die Titel, wir werfen sie ins Volk, schnappt euch das Land der Tanten, auch hier natürlich gerne ein Limerick zum Land der Tanten, die Hauptnichte, was steckt dahinter, der Bündel. Das finde ich ganz gut und ist das eine nicht die Vorsitzende des anderen. Das, da könnte ich mir eine Trilogie vorstellen, auf jeden Fall. Die Hauptnichte, das Land der Tanten, ja und jetzt reicht's, liebe Verwandte, ja, also fantastisch, grossartig, es ist so toll. Aber liegt da nicht noch mehr? Da liegen noch Formate. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall. Auch Creative Commons. Man muss in zehn Minuten eine Geschichte schreiben mit dem Titel oder sowas. Glaube ich viel. Es ist unendlich. Und da glaube ich auch, ehrlich gesagt, dass Vergess KI. Bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte. bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte tut mir den Gefallen und vergesst KI, lasst es einfach, die Zukunft ist zufallsgeneriert. Zufallsgeneratoren werden die Welt im Sturm erobern. Mein Kopf rast gerade. Wie wär's denn, wenn wir einen Zufallsgenerator machen und dann jede Woche, jede Woche geben wir einem Autoren, wir kennen ja viele Autoren aus unserer kleinen Medienbubble, jede Woche geben wir einem Autoren die Aufgabe, zu einem dieser Titel eine Mini-Kurzgeschichte zu schreiben. Kurze Kurzgeschichte, bitte. Bitte kurz, bitte wirklich. Eine kurze Kurzgeschichte, Minigeschichte zu schreiben. Und das ist der Podcast. Der neue Podcast ist dann jede Woche eine neue Geschichte. Aber sind die Geschichten noch nicht einfach schlechter als die, die die Autoren normalerweise schreiben würden? Und genau da liegt der Spaß. Und genau daran müssen wir noch arbeiten. Genau daran ist Wachstumspotenzial, dass die Leute denken, Moment mal, das muss doch besser werden. Das kann ich doch selber eine bessere Geschichte schreiben. Ja, aber diese Autoren, die beantragen, die wollen sich ja nicht blamieren. Und man weiß nicht, welcher Autor es ist. Doch. Ach so. Gut. Aber vielleicht nicht. Naja. Naja, dass du sagst, wir haben fünf Autoren angefragt, und dann lesen wir. Es ist einer, es ist entweder Tommy Schmidt, Tarkan Baci, Florentin Will, Stellanthitz oder Max Bierhals. Und wir haben alle fünf angefragt und die haben fünf Geschichten präsentiert und am Ende muss der Zuschauer raten, welche Geschichte von wem war. Und das Problem, ab Folge sieben sind die Autoren so unbekannt, dass der Zuschauer daran keinen Spaß hat, weil er die alle nicht kennt. Ja, noch weniger Spaß hat er als zu Folge 1. Ihr glaubt, ihr könnt noch weniger Spaß haben, schaltet nächste Woche wieder mal ein. Aber ganz ehrlich, da liegt was an Formaten, Ideen oder Rubriken im Podcast. Ja, da liegt was in der Luft. Da liegt was in der Luft. Ich habe mich so aufgeregtuckt. Dass du zu tief eingeatmet hast. Ich habe mich an den ganz vielen Ideen hier rumschwirren verschluckt. Aber kann man nicht, oder? Man kann nicht zu viel atmen. Dass der Körper sagt, jetzt ist zu viel. Seitdem ich gehört habe, dass man, wenn man zu viel Wasser trinkt, stirbt, bitter ich hinter jeder Ecke die Gefahr. Wenn du zu viel hörst, kannst du sterben, wenn du zu viel riechst. Man darf nicht zu viel riechen. Man darf nicht zu viel lesen. Zwei Dinge haben mich wahnsinnig gemacht. Einmal habe ich gehört, dass man seine Zunge verschlucken kann. Oh, hör auf jetzt. Seitdem kann man mich nicht mehr gebrauchen. Hör auf, das ist gemein, sowas darfst du nicht sagen. Ja, und dann doch, er solltest du auch hören. Das ist schon mal, Jürgen Klien ist mir schon mal passiert, er hat seine Zunge verschluckt. Wie schlimm ist das denn? How is this even possible? Dreht man sich dann auf rechts, wird man dann auf links gedreht? Sind wir auf links gedreht, haben wir alle unsere Zunge verschwunden. Ja, du musst dann einmal den gesamten Körper durch den Mund einmal umkrempeln. Wir müssen uns umkrempeln und dann habe ich gehört, dass man, wenn man zu viel Wasser trinkt, sterben kann. Ja, ich hatte Todesangst. Ich lag im Bett, weil ich einen Tag, ich glaube, sechs Liter waren es, sechs Liter Wasser getrunken habe an einem Tag, und ich lag im Bett und ich habe mich nicht gut gefühlt, und ich dachte, das war's. Das ist nicht gut gefühlt? Nee, ich habe mich nicht gut gefühlt. Wie hast du dich gefühlt? Ja, halt, also es ist schwer, wie fühlt sich der Tod an? Wässrig. Ich habe nicht zu viel Wasser. Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber das ist das Problem. Manchmal hat man Gefühle, die kann man zuordnen, manchmal Gefühle, die kann man nicht zuordnen, und denkt, ja, das muss tot sein. Das bei Tod, per Definition weiß niemand, wie sich der Tod anfühlt. Das heißt, jedes neue Gefühl könnte quasi der Tod sein. Ich habe das, schiebst du manchmal gerade auch ein bisschen auf die Situation, aber gerade habe ich manchmal so ein Unwohlsein, ich weiß nicht, woher es kommt. Hast du es auch? Dieses, dieses Zuhause sein, vielleicht auch ein bisschen. Das kann schon auch sein. Bei dir ist es vielleicht, weil du zu viel Wasser getrunken hast. Kann auch sein, ja. Aber ich habe es ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, manchmal hat man so ein, man kann es nicht zuordnen, aber vielleicht sterbe ich auch einfach. Aber mein Problem ist, ich mache denselben Fehler immer wieder. Ich hole mir jeden Morgen ein Netz Zitronen und schneide die auf und drücke die aus und dann habe ich ein ganzes Glas voller Zitronensaft. Reiner Zitronensaft. Ganz viel Zitronensaft. Deswegen hast du keine Zähne mehr. Ja, ganz viel Zitronensaft. Und dann denke ich mir, ah, ich bin clever, damit ich mehr trinke über den Tag, tue ich mir das in Wasserflaschen. Aber dann ist es immer so fucking sauer, dass ich es immer noch weiter verdünne und noch mehr, noch mehr baum muss. Und deswegen hast du da, hast du gerade eine Mateflasche, hinter dir stehen, ist da Zitronensaft drin? Da ist keine Zitrone drin, nee, aber zu Hause, für meinen Kühlschrank habe ich immer neue Flaschen und ich muss es immer, jeden Morgen mache ich viel zu viel Zitronensaft, weil ich mache ein Glas Zitronensaft für zwei Flaschen. Oder am Ende, nein, ein Glas Zitronensaft sind halt acht Flaschen oder so. Und dann trinkst du halt acht Liter jeden Tag. Und dann trink ich ja für den ganzen Tag das weg. Kann nicht schlecht sein. Und diese fucking Zitronen, die machen mir halt alles kaputt. Diese dummen, lachenden, gelben... Geh auf, die jetzt so kaufen. Nein, diese scheiß Biester hängen dann immer rum. Du musst sie nicht kaufen. Aber was soll ich denn eine Zitrone kaufen? Du musst sie in Netzen kaufen. Die werden so gefangen. Werden die so gefangen? Ja, mit so einem Lassoso, an dem so ein Netz ist, und dann werden so fünf Zitronen gefangen.
Der Zitronenfänger von Walter Ulbricht, auch ein tolles Buch.
Tolles Buch, leider komplettes Plagiat, muss man sagen.
Komplettes Plagiat, wurde er komplett abgeschrieben, von der spanischen Telenovela eins zu eins mitgeschrieben.
Vielen Dank nochmal an unseren Leser Jorge, der uns darauf hingewiesen hat. Jorge hat uns erzählt, dass der Zitronenfänger einzelne Klaut ist. Aber ja, man weiß es nicht, wenn man es liest, denkt man sich erstmal, wahnsinnige Geschichte. Wahnsinnige Geschichte. Und habe ich so auch nicht gewusst, dass dann doch in Mexiko die Arbeitsbedingungen so sind. Ja, dass da jede einzelne Zitrone hinterhergelaufen werden muss. Handgefangen ist. Mit Keschern und Lassos und grossen Handschuhen müssen die alle gefangen werden, die Zitronen. Perlentaucher und Zitronenfänger. Oh, Perlentaucher ist ein toller Job, oder? Du bist den ganzen Tag allein, kannst Podcast hören. Aber ist nicht deren Challenge, dass sie kein Sauerstoffgerät haben? Du kannst Podcast hören unter Wasser? Ja, natürlich. Hast du gerade einen Aussetzer? Nein. Hast du gerade einen mentalen Breakdown? Natürlich, hä? Guck mich mal nicht so an. Warum? Wie willst du denn? Ich kann so unter Wasser Podcasts hören. Du kannst sogar im Pool Lautsprecher installieren und dann hörst du Musik oder Podcasts unter Wasser. Weil Wasser leitet ja Schallwellen viel besser als Luft. Das heißt, du hast da so einen kleinen Mini-Lautsprecher. Machst du das mit deinen Podcast-Millionen? Machst du das mit deinen Rocket-Bien-Podcast-Millionen, den Pool kaufen, hast du in deiner Badewanne, Flurdeen, guck mich an. Nein, ich hab keinen Lautsprecher. Hast du in deiner Badewanne einen Lautsprecher? Nein, ich hab keinen Lautsprecher. Aber ich weiß, dass es das gibt, und es ist gut. Und deswegen könnte man natürlich auch sagen ... Pantow haben den besten Job der Welt. wir installieren einen riesigen Lautsprecher unten an Trash Island dran, so dass im Umkreis oder im Radio so durchsagen und dann Liebe Mitbewohner von Trash Island. Horch horch! Das ist das Moin Moin von Trash Island.
Horch horch!
Ja.
Zitronen laufen frei herum. Bitte lassen Sie sie nicht entkommen. Die vermehren sich wie Scheisse. Fangen Sie sie im Netzen ... Unsere Regierung ist ganz schön derb. Klar, war das so von so einem Twitch-Chat-Kack-Regierung. Natürlich ist die Derb. Natürlich sind die Derb. Poggers. Die Poggers. Monk-Eyes, Leute. Die Zitronen laufen überall rum, Monk-Eyes. Das ist ein Scheißland, glaube ich. Ich glaube, das ist schon ganz gut. Ich meine, Müll stinkt ja auch nicht ewig, oder? Trash Island. Trash Islands macht es ein bisschen cooler.
Das stimmt. Weil es klingt dann ein bisschen zu erhaben.
Da ist so eine lange Kette und dann kommt die nächste Insel und an der noch mal eine lange Kette und die nächste Insel. Die fahren dann immer so aneinander an der Reihe durch.
Jetzt erinnert es mich an Valyrian.
Valyrian?
Valyrian. Valyrian?
Oblivion. Oblivion! Der ist so boring. Ach ja! Stimmt, den habe ich auch gesehen. Und Tom Cruise so, ach ja! Ach ja, stimmt! Oblivion! Das ist 96! Oblivion! Ach ja, ich am Berg dran, ja, ja, ja. Und Morgan Freeman. Ach ja! Wir wussten nicht, dass die unseren Podcast hören, bis jetzt, bis sie uns ganz erleichtert die Nachricht geschrieben haben. Ja, ich habe mich wieder daran erinnert. Toll. Nee, Valyrian, das ist doch die Stadt, die tausend Ländenstädte alle docken sich an. Das ist wie ein Trash Island im Weltall. Nein, nein, nein, das hast du geträumt. Habt eine schöne Woche. Eine fantastische Woche. Habt eine schöne Woche. Wir freuen uns natürlich auf eure Interpretation der zehn Buchtitel, der Spiegel Beste der Liste, der Zufallsgeneratoren Namen können wir auch veröffentlichen, ansonsten haut rein. Können wir mal bitte eine Zeitschrift rausbringen? Alle bringen noch Zeitschriften raus. Joko und so und Barbara Schöneberger und so. Ja klar, wenn wir eine Zufallsgeneratoren-Zeitschrift rausbringen mit zufalls generierten Artikeln und Spiegel-Bestsellerliste mit zufälligen, alles in dieser Zeitschrift ist random. Wie würde das Magazin heißen? Random. Okay. Und es ist einfach, das Titelbild ist ein random Bild aus dem Internet, die Überschrift passt gar nicht. Wie viel kostet das? Weiß ich nicht. Es wird ausgewürfelt an der Kasse. Ja, und alles, jeder Artikel ist Random Shit. Ja. Und dann immer so eine Liste, hinten steht ja immer die Bestsellerliste mit Random-Namen, aber es ist so. Stell dir vor, das ist das erfolgreichste Magazin der Welt und die Leute lesen nur noch random und dann habe ich letztens in der random gelesen. Aber ist es nicht perfekt, ist es nicht die Antwort auf unseren Zeitgeist gerade, weil bei uns ist alles nicht mehr random. Wir hören ja eben nicht mehr... Zu konstruiert, die Algorithmen kontrollieren uns. Ne, genau, wir hören ja nicht mehr nur Radio, Radio ist ja deswegen geil, weil random Shit kommt. Sehr gut. Hören wir nicht mehr, wir gucken nicht mehr lineares Fernsehen, wo Dinge kommen, die wir nicht beeinflussen können. Wir beeinflussen unsere Bubble. Unser Leben ist so bubblig, weil wir alles uns selber, wir kreieren unsere Wirklichkeit. Und random holt uns da raus. Aber jedes Magazin muss anders sein. Zwei random Ausgaben dürfen nicht gleich sein. Die muss jedes neue random generiert sein. Wie willst du denn die Druckkosten bezahlen? Wie willst du denn diese ganzen Druckkosten bezahlen? Mit unseren Einnahmen von Perspectives,
verdammt nochmal. Ach ja, ganz vergessen.
Da kommt gut Geld rein, tatsächlich.
Ach ja, bestimmt.
Habt eine schöne Woche,
wir heben ab, wir
schmeissen unseren knatternden Motor auf und fahren.
Wir stechen in die sieben Weltmeere
mit unserem Land.
It's the West Bird Production.